RUPP: Well, I'm very pleased, delighted to
welcome all of you to this Sorensen Distinguished
Lecture on the U.N. And Gillian Sorensen is
here. I want to express appreciation from
all of us to you, Gillian. Maybe you could
even stand up.
(APPLAUSE)
I have the privilege of introducing Valerie
Amos who will be our Gillian Sorensen lecturer.
Valerie was born in Georgetown, Guyana. She
went -- moved to the U.K. when she was nine
years old and was educated in the U.K. I just
asked her because her accent was so flawlessly
U.K. whether her first language was also English
-- British English -- and the answer is, it
was.
She's had a very distinguished career for
more than twenty-five years in international
relations in very senior leadership positions.
Since July 2010, she was -- she has been the
U.N. under-general-secretary for humanitarian
affairs and emergency relief coordinator.
For those of us involved in these sorts of
events, we all -- we think of her as the head
of OCHA.
She has also served as a U.K. high commissioner
to Australia. She has served as well in the
U.K. Cabinet as the minister responsible for
international development.
A very distinguished career; lots more to
it. You can read about it in your program.
I now have the great honor of presenting to
you Valerie Amos who will speak for about
fifteen minutes after which she and I will
have a brief conversation and then we'll open
it up for your questions and comments.
Thank you very much for being with us.
(APPLAUSE)
AMOS: Professor Rupp, thank you very much,
indeed. And thank you, everyone. Good evening.
It's a great pleasure to be here at the Council
on Foreign Relations, an institution with
I think has provided a platform for critical
engagement and discussion into the pressing
issues of our time -- global governance, conflict,
peace, human rights and security.
And I'm particularly pleased to be joining
a list of distinguished contributors to the
Sorensen Lecture Series on the United Nations.
The commitment of Ted C. Sorensen, a trusted
advisor to President Kennedy, and to Gillian
Martin Sorensen to the U.N. principles is
invaluable. And this lecture series, I think,
is critical because it gives the United Nations
and its senior members an opportunity to reflect
on our work, on our principles and the challenges
that are facing us.
For me, this lecture comes at a particularly
critical time when the world is grappling
with a series of challenges which are bringing
us closer together and also pushing us wider
apart, and when we are seeking to redefine
the role of the nation state, of governments
and of the United Nations, given the complex
set of challenges which are facing us.
This week alone, horrific events in France
and Nigeria have led, for example, to searching
questions about the nature of terrorism, security,
freedom of speech and religion, the limits
or otherwise of press freedom, tolerance,
racism, inequality, the impact of social media
and the Internet, the lack of connectivity
between people and cultures and the quality
of global leadership.
And it's clear that we do not have all the
answers as we're dealing with phenomena which
are very often outside our experience -- reports
of a ten-year-old suicide bomber, a young
girl; deliberate targeted killing of journalists,
cartoonists whose job it was to challenge
us to look at our world in different ways;
and anti-Semitic attacks aimed at further
fueling tensions between Jews and Muslims.
And in the midst of that hatred and brutality,
an outpouring of global solidarity, even as
citizens question themselves and their leaders
about the kind of world we're living in and
the kind of future we want to have.
Our world seems to be in turmoil. And nowhere
is this more evident than in the work that
I do in humanitarian affairs; so many contradictions
played out daily as we see the impact of conflict
and crisis on people's day-to-day lives.
I've often said that in our work, we see the
worst of humanity and the very best -- mindless
violence, abuse, particularly of women and
children, and in the midst of it all, people
sharing what little they have, supporting,
protecting and helping each other.
Humanitarian work is under significant pressure
as we face growing needs around the world.
This year, 2015, 78 million people in twenty-two
countries require urgent humanitarian assistance
and we estimate that it will cost $16.4 billion
for us to help them. That money will provide
urgently needed shelter, essential health
care, education, food. It will help people
to survive.
But what it will not do is help people to
rebuild their lives because without resolution
to conflict, people will continue to flee
brutality; and without early warning systems
and risk mitigation measures, people will
continue to suffer the impact of hurricanes,
drought, floods and other natural disasters.
Without investment in mitigation and other
measures, climate change will deepen the impact
of recurrent natural disasters.
The United Nations was founded to promote
global peace and security, to protect people's
human rights and to facilitate development.
Every year, more is expected of the U.N. And
yet, it is an organization which is limited
not by the vision of its founders but by its
members today -- 193 countries, each with
different interests and perspectives reflecting
the changes we have seen in the nearly seventy
years of the organization's history.
The United Nations has needed to change as
the world has changed and we have seen some
significant successes. Just in my work, the
United Nation provides food to 90 million
people in 80 countries every year; vaccinates
58 percent of the world's children, saving
3 million lives a year; assists over 38.7
million refugees and people feeling war, famine
or prosecution; keeps peace with 120,000 peacekeepers
in sixteen operations on four continents;
fights poverty; helps to improve the health
and well-being of 420 million of the rural
poor and promotes and protects human rights
through some 80 treaties and declarations.
But somehow we forget all that because we
focus particularly, I think, on the political
side of the United Nations -- the side of
the United Nations which uses diplomacy to
prevent conflict and assists some sixty countries
a year with their elections.
But as with all organizations, with growth
has come more bureaucracy, less flexibility.
And we have seen changes in power dynamics
between countries and regions reflected in
the ways that issues are debated and discussed
-- indeed, in the way that they are resolved.
And we see this, as well, in humanitarian
work. More is expected of us than ever before.
We're called on to provide life-saving assistance
and protection of civilians, but we're not
necessarily given the tools to do it.
Civilians are killed and injured in targeted
or indiscriminate attacks in violation of
international humanitarian law and often with
complete impunity. I cannot remember the number
of times I have reported to the Security Council
and asked them to make strong statements,
which they do, about what is happening in
the world, but it doesn't necessarily change
what is happening on the ground.
Eighty-two percent of the people who were
killed or injured by explosive weapons in
2013, the last time we have figures, were
civilians. Violence and other forms of persecution
force an average of 23,000 people per day
-- per day -- to leave their homes to seek
protection elsewhere.
Too often, humanitarian organizations are
called on to fill the glaring gaps that emerge
when states neglect to fulfill their duty
to safeguard their citizens. Think, for example,
Syria or South Sudan; or where, as a result
of conflict, the state apparatus has become
weak, fragmented or almost nonexistent, as
in the case of Somalia or the Central African
Republic.
Humanitarian actors are increasingly being
called on to deal with the consequences of
crises that essentially have their roots in
a complex set of interrelated factors -- poor
governance, political paralysis, underdevelopment,
rising levels of poverty and inequality. And
these dynamics in many countries are overlaid
by the growth of terrorists and radical armed
groups and challenges to democratization,
which create further instability. Add to this
mix climate change, environmental degradation,
population growth in some parts of the world
and the consequences of increasing levels
of internal displacement and forced migration.
The average length of conflict-induced development
is a staggering seventeen years. Despite the
economic gains we have seen in many countries,
inequality is rising and poverty and instability
often go hand-in-hand.
Half of the world's extreme poor live in fragile
states. We're seeing a convergence of global
trends which is increasing the risk of major
crises, their scope and complexity.
Conflict and complex emergencies drove over
75 percent of humanitarian response needs
last year and most of the conflicts we are
responding to have implications far beyond
their borders. The crises in Iraq and Syria,
for example, have consequences across the
whole of the Middle East and beyond.
The fall of Gaddafi in Libya led to major
insecurity and spread of weapons across Western
Central Africa, the impact of which is still
being felt today. And in many of the conflict
zones in which we work, there has been a manifest
failure by political leaders to be inclusive
in their protection of their people and to
realize that state sovereignty is a responsibility
rather than one of the spoils of being in
power.
Humanitarian workers, because of the lifesaving
nature of our work, need to be impartial;
we need to be neutral. We have to be on the
side of the people, not on the side of governments
or armed groups where there is conflict.
This means that we operate in highly-pressurized
and political environments where attempts
are made to use humanitarian action to pursue
political or security ends. This has become
more and more challenging as we have worked
to keep humanitarian response separate from
political imperatives in places like Syria,
Iraq, Ukraine and Gaza.
We have a responsibility to be strong advocates
for the people caught in the midst of conflict.
And many governments don't like what we say.
And we are constantly, literally and figuratively,
under fire.
Working in conflict zones where international
humanitarian law is flagrantly violated is
dangerous. In 2013, violence against humanitarian
aid operations hit an all-time high with 251
separate attacks in which 155 aid workers
were killed and 134 were kidnapped.
But despite the continued danger, humanitarian
groups continue to provide life-saving assistance
to millions of people around the world every
single day. And we do everything we can to
ensure that we can continue to work.
We negotiate with governments and armed groups;
we use those with influence over warring parties
to help us gain access; we use the Security
Council to push for resolutions which will
make a difference. We have to be operationally
effective and we have to be politically astute.
We have to be strong advocates, good communicators.
We have to make the case, we have to raise
the money. And crucially, we have to be good
leaders, demonstrating impact and pushing
for change.
The challenges facing organizations working
in the humanitarian field is a microcosm of
the challenges facing the entire United Nations.
How do we live up to the values of the U.N.
charter? How do we safeguard human rights,
protect civilians and help secure a more peaceful
and a more just world? How do we promote more
active global citizenship? And how do we help
the people of the world to connect and see
the value of inclusivity as well as of diversity
and difference?
From our work, we know that the only way to
break the cycle of violence which continues
to threaten global peace and stability is
for political actors to work with communities
to find sustainable solutions to these crises.
The need is greater than ever for states to
live up to their responsibility to protect
civilians from harm, and when states fail
to do so for others, including multilateral
institutions, to step in.
The tools available to the international community
now appear extremely limited in light of the
complex set of challenges we face. We need
a stronger and, dare I say it, perhaps more
interventionist global architecture to deal
with the humanitarian consequences of conflict.
I recognize that this would come with major
risks, given global power dynamics and other
differences around the world. But I do have
to say that after every crisis, we say 'never
again', and yet, it always happens again.
We have a body of international humanitarian
law which over time has given us the means
to tackle the challenges arising from conflicts
-- a set of rules. The problem is its lack
of implementation.
We will, of course, continue to push for civilians
to be protected in conflict, be it calling
on U.N. member states to deliver on their
duty to protect their citizens or highlighting
to governments and militaries the devastating
impact that the use of explosive weapons has
on people living in densely populated urban
areas.
Implementation requires stronger vision and
commitment from governments and multilateral
institutions, as well as from humanitarian
agencies. It is also no longer acceptable
that still less than half of 1 percent of
all international aid is spent on disaster
preparedness and prevention.
Finding the right approach to these and other
challenges is a priority for the consultations
leading up to the 2016 World Humanitarian
Summit, the first ever such summit which has
been called for by the U.N. secretary general.
At that summit, we will have a unique opportunity
to reshape our approach to humanitarian aid,
and indeed, the way that we do humanitarian
business.
We all face a choice. We can continue to affect
peaceful change, or we can truly transform
the way we approach complex problems in a
way that better reflects today's reality.
I think we should try to do the latter, for
the sake of the millions of people around
the world today who frankly deserve better
from all of us. Thank you very much.
(APPLAUSE)
RUPP: Thank you.
AMOS: I hope that's not my phone.
(LAUGHTER)
RUPP: I'm sure you turned it off just as everyone
else.
AMOS: I tried.
RUPP: Valerie, thank you very much for that
accurate description of just how somber the
current situation we all face is, and also
the very upbeat portrayal of the humanitarian
mandate that you have lived now for these
multiple years. Thank you on both counts.
I share all of your hopes and aspirations
for how we might be able to do better. But
I -- I guess I'd like in a -- the couple minutes
we have before we open up to questions to
hear a little bit more of your experience
down on the ground -- down to earth.
You've had the really rare experience of being
in a leadership position for an individual
influential country, namely, Great Britain,
and also in -- in your role, your very senior
role at the U.N.
Maybe you could tell us a little bit about
an example of a high point and a low point
in -- in each of those involvements or ways
in which the two roles are different.
AMOS: I suppose the thing that I -- I think
is the lowest point for me, and many people
tell me it should not be, is that I really
feel that we have failed the people of Syria.
I've been in this job for four years and Syria
has really, I think, defined the time that
I have been in this job.
And when I first visited Syria four years
ago, I was trying to persuade the government
that they had a humanitarian crisis on their
hands as a result of the conflict. And at
that time, we were talking about a million
people inside Syria in -- in need of some
form of humanitarian assistance. In just four
years, that number has climbed to over 12
million.
I mean, we have watched that happen; we as
a world have watched that happen. More than
3 million people have fled to neighboring
countries. The -- the brutality, the level
of brutality that people are facing is indescribable.
I have personally, and so have my colleagues,
spent a huge amount of time getting aid. I
mean, I think it's -- it -- what -- what humanitarian
workers have been able to continue doing in
Syria is absolutely extraordinary in the most
difficult and dangerous circumstances. And
we are feeding millions of people, getting
health care to millions of people, but I still
feel that we have failed because we have watched
-- we have watched a country descend into
-- into war and conflict and we haven't been
able to stop it.
And I think I, with everyone in a position
of some responsibility and authority, needs
to take some responsibility for that, whatever
I have been able to do. And people keep reminding
me that I have been able to do a lot. So,
I see that as -- I see that very much as a
low point.
I think as a high point, I -- I -- in my career
and in the work that I do, it is just the
extraordinary people that I meet every single
day. I mean, I've been to some of the worst
places in the world -- Central African Republic,
Somalia, Afghanistan, South Sudan, Democratic
Republic of the Congo. I've watched people
fleeing violence; I've watched children on
the brink of death in malnutrition centers.
And yet, I've seen the extraordinary hope
that people have that the world will help
and support them and that they will come out
of this.
And I've seen people want to help themselves
from day one. I remember last year when I
went to the Philippines within days of Typhoon
Haiyan and Tacloban was absolutely devastated.
There was hardly a building left standing.
And yet -- yet, people within hours were trying
to find ways of creating, you know, shelter
for their families whilst at the same time
trying to find the bodies of those that were
missing. I mean, and I kept saying, "This
is a resilience that -- that we should -- a
level of resilience that we should not expect
people to have, and yet they do have it."
So, you know, this has been the most extraordinary
job I've ever had, precisely because in the
midst of utter devastation, people remain
strong and extremely positive.
RUPP: Well, that's -- having shared with you
going to all of those places you mentioned,
I certainly agree with that. And I think it
is a -- when people ask you, well, doesn't
it get depressing, the response to that is
the one you just gave -- is as awful as it
is, there are people who are -- demonstrate
the resilience and the -- and the will to
not only help themselves, but help others
-- that it brings out the best in people.
But let's go back to the low point, to Syria.
As you know, the International Rescue Committee
is involved in Syria and in all the countries
surrounding Syria on all of the fronts that
you mentioned.
And I -- it has -- the crisis has accelerated
to a point where it is absolutely an incredible
tragedy for all those involved. And we in
the international community have watched it
accelerate from a very small problem to now
into the largest problem that the international
community has faced in a long time.
You mentioned that -- that international relief
and development organizations have to exemplify
impartiality in the way in which their goods
or services are distributed. You mentioned
neutrality. You didn't mention independence,
but I'm sure you agree operational independence
is also critical.
Given the commitment to neutrality, in particular,
how -- how do you think we can or should have
been more effective in dealing -- we in the
humanitarian community -- with the crisis
in Syria?
AMOS: I think it -- I think it's not just
a problem for the humanitarian community.
I mean, I think that -- I think that is part
of the problem. The big issue in Syria is
that we have not managed to find a political
solution to a major political crisis in -- in
that country.
So, you know, humanitarian organizations and
humanitarian workers have been doing everything
they can -- so, working from inside Syria,
working across borders from Turkey, Jordan.
I mean, there are some NGOs doing extraordinary
work that have been working, particularly
from Turkey, over many, many years, establishing
relations with communities in the north of
Syria that has actually allowed them to continue
working there even now when those areas are
under ISIL control. We don't know how much
longer that will last but they're able to
work there because the communities themselves
want them to be there and are challenging
ISIL as ISIL is trying to get those organizations
out.
I think that there are -- you know, there
were questions raised, for example, about
the fact that the United Nations was working
inside Syria, working with the government
of Syria to get aid across conflict lines
inside Syria. I absolutely defend the decision
to do that because our job was to try to reach
all Syrians in need of aid, and this is a
government that still controls territory and
still -- still -- still controls a security
apparatus, for example.
We work with the government; we've worked
with -- with armed groups. It's been a very
challenging environment because of the proliferation
of different armed groups on the ground.
Perhaps we could have pressured the Security
Council earlier to get some of the resolutions
that we did. But the -- the political differences,
particularly between the permanent five of
the Security Council, I think really led to
a degree of stasis at the beginning of the
crisis because there simply wasn't an agreed
way of moving forward, even though I think
on humanitarian issues, there was a sense
in which everyone agreed that more needed
to be done to deal with the humanitarian consequences
of conflict.
RUPP: In your comments just now you mentioned
about the -- the growth of programs in -- in
the United Nations and -- and therefore an
increase in bureaucracy and a reduction in
flexibility. That last comment about the difficulty
in the response of the U.N. would call further
attention to that set of issues. So, what's
the long-term solution to that problem?
AMOS: One of the things that we're looking
at in the run-up to this World Humanitarian
Summit is essentially how do we do our business.
Are we doing -- are we conducting humanitarian
operations in the best possible way? Should
we be working with a wider range of partners?
What is the -- what is the added value of
U.N. organizations in these situations? How
can you best support the local communities
on the ground who are there and present and
already have the relationship?
So, there are a big set of questions, I think,
which we have to continue to ask ourselves
about what we're doing, why we're doing it,
what needs the support, if you like, of the
multilateral system, as opposed to what can
be done at the local level. And it's -- it's
-- it's extraordinarily difficult in conflict
situations. It's much more straightforward
in a natural disaster situation.
But in a conflict situation where you have
so many different individuals and organizations
on the ground at war with each other, I think
you need the United Nations and, as it were,
the -- the independence of the United Nations
system. But therein also lies some challenges,
because of course the United Nations has,
you know, it has a political dimension, it
has a peacekeeping dimension, a development
dimension, a humanitarian dimension; we are
not always seen as neutral. We're not always
seen as independent.
RUPP: Well, let's just -- and then -- then
we will open up to others. But let's take
one last example. We've all been struck with
the Ebola crisis in West Africa. That's an
example where the question of lack of flexibility
or rigidity or organizational interaction
can't help but arise.Could you comment on
how -- give a grade to the international community
on responding to Ebola, or international community
and West African communities.
AMOS: I think Ebola is -- is probably the
most complex coordination challenge that the
international community has ever had to -- to
face. Because this is not just a health crisis;
this is a major economic crisis for the countries
of West Africa. It's a major social crisis
for those countries, as well, with some big
questions and challenges around how communities
traditionally operate.
We make lots of assumptions, I think, in the
criticisms that have been made of the Ebola
response about how we think health care is
managed in those countries. These are countries
that are post-conflict countries -- very poor
infrastructure. In most of those countries,
in the rural areas, people probably haven't
even seen a clinic or a health worker.
So, to then suddenly try to put in place structures
to help to deal with something as contagious
as Ebola, particularly when you're saying
to people that your traditional practices
in terms of how you bury your dead can no
longer be carried out, I mean, it is a -- it's
a -- it's a huge challenge, not just for the
U.N., but for the whole international community,
and particularly for the governments of those
countries.
I think we all accept that we were too slow
in terms of bringing those coordination elements
together. But the way that the health aspects
of this kind of replicated themselves so quickly
over time was something which I think surprised
us all.
RUPP: OK, well, thank you very much for your
-- your candor and your recognition that there
are challenges yet to be addressed.
I would like to open it now to questions from
the floor. When I recognize you, please stand.
Say your name and any other identification
you'd like to give and then put a question
-- not -- not a speech, but a question would
be good.
Yes?
QUESTION: Jeff Laurenti.
Thank you, Madam Under-Secretary-General,
and then for your lecture, but even more importantly,
for having been doing God's work, often at
the gates of hell.
I was struck by a passing reference you made,
quote, "We need stronger and, dare I say,
perhaps more interventionist global architecture"
in order to deal with the emergencies, humanitarian
crises occasioned by conflict. And so, you
have put something very big out there.
I wonder if you...
AMOS: In a very gentle voice.
(LAUGHTER)
QUESTION: In a very gentle voice.
I -- I wonder if you could suggest to us what
you personally think that architecture -- what
the pillars and walls or whatever of that
interventionist architecture might be. How,
in situations where you have had political
kind of international unity -- Congo, Afghanistan
-- would it have made a difference? And how,
in situations where you haven't had unity
among the Security Council members -- Syria
or arguably Gaza -- would it make a difference
to have a so-called interventionist architecture?
RUPP: Jeff, I thank you for putting a question
mark by the end of that.
(LAUGHTER)
AMOS: It's a huge question and I wanted to
put it out there.And I don't have -- I don't
have all the elements as to what the architecture
might look like.
You know, a few years ago, we talked about
the concept of responsibility to protect and
what that might mean. And we haven't been
able to deliver on that.
And it's -- it's partly because we -- you
know, what I've seen in the time that I've
been at the U.N. is -- and my colleagues at
the International Committee of the Red Cross
talk about this, too -- a more kind of aggressive
use of state sovereignty by member states
of the United Nations, basically to prevent
things happening and to prevent the United
Nations and the sort of multilateral system
and others calling them to account.
And quite frankly, I -- I think that there
is not enough calling to account; that you
have states that sign up to a whole set of
treaties, that sign up to the U.N. charter
-- it carries responsibility with it. And
there isn't -- there isn't sufficiently -- sufficient,
in my view, accountability linked to that
membership of the United Nations and that,
as it were, almost passive acceptance of a
commitment to the values of the U.N. charter.
So, you know, I don't know what the different
elements of this might look -- but, I mean,
I actually feel very strongly that we have
a strong body of international humanitarian
law which we are not putting into practice.
I have on many occasions exhorted the Security
Council members to recognize flagrant violations
of international humanitarian law -- and they
do, and then there is no action after that.
So, I ask -- so, I'm asking the question,
in the modern world where we are proud of
that international architecture, where we
are proud of the Geneva Conventions, where
we are proud of the progress that we have
made -- and we have made progress; I mean,
I think part of the problem is that we focus
on the negative not on the positive, and we
have made progress.
But at the same time, to -- to watch as, you
know, millions of people are forced to flee
as there is abuse on an unprecedented scale
of girls and women in many countries across
the world and action is not being taken in
relation to this, I ask the question, should
we not be more interventionist?
Now, when -- and I say there -- I say it because
when you talk about intervention, people always
think it means boots on the ground; it means
that you're invading somebody else's country.
And that is not necessarily the question that
I'm asking. I'm asking a question about an
architecture that we already have, a body
of rules and law that we already have that
we are not holding ourselves accountable to.
And I see this as a significant failure.
Within the United Nations ourselves, we have
been doing some soul searching on the issue
of human rights and particularly post what
happened in Sri Lanka and criticisms that
the United Nations did not, sufficiently early,
raise the temperature and call the fact that
human right -- major human rights abuses were
being carried out in Sri Lanka. And it is
-- it's caused us as United Nations to completely
rethink how we do this.
And the secretary general and the deputy secretary-general
is now leading something called the Human
Rights Up Front agenda, which is about putting
the recognition and -- and commitment to human
rights, which is a founding element of the
U.N. charter, front and center of our work.
But it's not going to be enough for us to
do that from an organizational perspective
if our member states don't buy into this.
So, these are the questions that are -- that
I'm -- that I'm asking. And yes, we need to
market it if we're associated with it but
let's not have a whole 'nother big singing,
dancing organization. Let's have some accountability,
I say.
RUPP: OK, accountability -- that would be
very helpful. Yes?
(LAUGHTER)
AMOS: That's classic British understatement
from an American.
(LAUGHTER)
QUESTION: Thank you, George. My name is David
Phillips with Columbia University.
A couple of your predecessors -- Jan Egeland,
Sergio de Mello come to mind -- reinvented
the role of emergency relief coordinator as
the U.N.'s chief advocate. In light of your
experience in Syria, do you feel that enough
was done to name and shame countries on the
Security Council who became accomplices to
the human suffering? And is neutrality really
a cherished principle, or does it merely contribute
to the misery of victims?
AMOS: Well, whose neutrality? Can you say
whose neutrality you're referring to? Because
the neutrality that I'm talking about is the
importance for humanitarian work of being
able to engage with and speak with everybody.
QUESTION: So, I'm not thinking about the neutrality
of humanitarian workers. I'm really thinking
specifically about your neutrality and your
voice and what you can do to mobilize the
political will to take on those countries
that become accomplices to crime.
AMOS: First of all, I think that -- that -- that
part of my -- my advocacy, and in a way, I
think that as this rather grand title I have
as emergency relief coordinator, that part
of that is actually about being on the side
of the people who are facing these atrocities.
And I've been very strong about that. I think
that it is about taking sides but I think
it's about taking the side of the people.
On the issue of -- of calling out and naming
and shaming, this -- this gets raised with
me frequently, particularly in relation to
members of the Security Council. And one of
the challenges I think that we have is with
respect to the issue of humanitarian work,
you very often find that the members of the
Security Council are speaking with one voice
-- I mean, you know, they have very, very
similar views. What they disagree about is
the political -- what is the political root
that will actually have an impact on the work
that I'm doing.
So, I rather famously once had someone say
to me, "You should stand up every week in
the Security Council and denounce Russia because
of Russia's closeness to Syria." I had to
actually disabuse them of the fact that that
in relation to humanitarian issues, Russia
had been extremely helpful to us in terms
of the relationship that we were able to open
up with the Syrian authorities to get access
to -- to various places.
So, it is always more complicated than it
appears on the outside because we're talking
about -- we're talking political differences
which have a significant impact on the humanitarian
work. But in the work that I am doing and
in the advocacy that I am doing, very often
I am being helped by countries which, on the
political side, have significant differences.
So, that's where the challenge comes, in terms
of that advocacy.
RUPP: Yes -- yes?
QUESTION: Hello, my name is -- I'm a journalist
at the -- Evelyn Leopold -- a journalist at
the U.N. who sits at Baroness Amos' feet.
AMOS: I hadn't noticed that before, but...
(LAUGHTER)
QUESTION: So, my question is how careful are
you, since walls have ears, how careful are
you when you brief the Security Council so
that Syria doesn't take it out on WFP or someone
else who needs the government to deliver a
-- and secondly, you said something about
putting humanitarian issues first. I thought
that's what the U.N. promised to do after
Rwanda.
AMOS: Just on your -- just on your second
point, I mean, I think that after Rwanda,
after Srebrenica, after a whole variety of
crises that we've seen in -- in the world,
that member states of the United Nations have
said "never again", and yet, we have not managed
to live up to that.
It was out of that that we got the whole issue
of, you know, the responsibility to protect
-- that where you had an issue in a country
where civilians needed protecting, that somehow
we would take a -- we would look at this differently.
But we have not been able to deliver on that
because of the importance within the U.N.
of the issue of state sovereignty and, you
know, as it were, noninterference in the domestic
affairs of another country. And how you deal
with that in a situation where civilians are
behind attacked, brutalized and violated is
difficult.
How careful I -- am I when I brief the Security
Council? I think I'm extremely frank and upfront
when I brief the Security Council, in what
are called close consultations, because I
think it's important that members of the Security
Council who are reporting back -- ambassadors
who are reporting back to their capitals hear
from me what the reality is on the ground
and what the implications of the actions that
Security Council members and others take,
have on our work.
And I don't feel that I hold back. And I think
if you speak to Security Council members,
they'll -- they will probably agree with that.
RUPP: OK. Yes, Don?
QUESTION: Donald Shriver of Union Theological
Seminary.
As we all know, when the U.N. started taking
seriously the principle of responsibility
to protect, it was offering a real collision
with the principle of natural sovereignty.
What is your reading of the experience of
the U.N. so far in undertaking responsibility
to protect without merely engaging in further
violent conflict with nationally sovereign
governments?
AMOS: I think it's been -- I think it's been
extremely difficult to -- for the U.N. to
-- to really apply the principle of responsibility
to protect because what you do have is governments
which then claim sovereignty. And I think
that even after the whole development of the
principle of responsibility to -- to -- to
protect, that actually nation states have
become even more aggressive in their use of
state sovereignty as a reason to prevent action
being taken to protect civilians.
We saw this in Syria where we had -- we had
to go to Security Council and get two resolutions
to enable us to cross the borders from, for
example, Turkey into Syria and also Jordan
and Iraq into Syria across border crossing
points, which on the Syrian side were not
held by the Syrian government. And I don't
think that the Syrian government has ever
forgiven me; they see me as personally responsible
for pushing the Security Council to agree
those resolutions.
For me, taking an approach which is how best
do we reach people across Syria who are in
need of help and assistance -- that had to
be the cornerstone of our policy. And Security
Council members agreed with that. And that's
why we got those resolutions passed.
And I think that there is a very odd thing
happening, which is that on the one hand,
you have governments at the United Nations
that are pushing harder and harder the issue
of state sovereignty whilst at the same time,
their citizens are connecting through social
media and the Internet and actually taking
less and less notice of their governments.
So, on the one hand, you need governments
to -- to put in place social programs, to
-- to provide basic social services and so
on, but very often you have their citizens
that are feeling that their governments are
becoming increasingly irrelevant. And how
you deal with that contradiction I think is
also going to be a question for us for the
future.
RUPP: Well, as we turn to another question,
I can't help observing that as -- as much
as you had words of praise for the international
humanitarian architecture, there do seem to
be some real problems that still need to be
addressed. And maybe in your next career,
you could work that out.
(LAUGHTER)
Are there -- I see a lot of men hands. Are
there some women? Yes?
QUESTION: Hi, I'm Marcia Biggs. I'm a filmmaker.
I'm working on a story on the Yazidi community
in Northern Iraq, targeted and attacked by
ISIS.
I'm just wondering if you consider that an
act of genocide and what the U.N. is doing
to try to retrieve the estimated 3,000 girls
that are still missing and widely believed
to be used as slaves and sold throughout the
region?
AMOS: There -- there are a number of minority
communities that have been targeted that need
support. There are -- there's contradictory
information about numbers and who and where.
And part of the responsibility, of course,
we have as United Nations is to try and get
as much data and information as we can so
that we are operating on the basis of information
that is as fact-based as possible.
In terms of the reported 3,000 girls that
are reported missing, we don't have data that
actually confirms that. I mean, there is a
lot of data that shows that a lot of women
and children, not just from minority communities,
but -- from across Iraq, but also in Syria,
have been targeted. There are widely different
-- different reports about the numbers.
And what we can do from our work on the humanitarian
side is to as much as possible get information
and data from different communities and the
different organizations that we are working
with, from the Red Crescent societies that
we are working with, with the Gulf charitable
organizations and others that are there on
the ground as to what they see and know so
that as much as possible we can work to get
those young women back.
QUESTION: (OFF-MIKE)
AMOS: It's -- I cannot say whether those numbers
are exaggerated. What I can say is that there
are wildly different -- differing numbers
about how many have disappeared.
In a way, you know, my perspective is one
young woman disappearing is too many. So,
you know, working to ensure that this doesn't
happen, working to ensure that there is adequate
protection for minorities, adequate protection
for women and girls is the crucial element
in all of this.
RUPP: OK, one final question. Yes? Yes? Someone
needs to give you a...
QUESTION: Hi, my name is Alexandra Zevallos-Ortiz
and I'm from Austria. I'm currently interning
with IPS at the United Nations and I've got
a question concerning the Syrian refugee crisis.
We spoke -- or we are currently speaking about
a failure of Europe and United States, basically
the Western world. And most part -- the highest
number of Syrian refugees have fled to the
-- to the neighboring countries.
I just wanted to know what's your position
concerning the Gulf states. Why hasn't -- haven't
they established a single refugee camp within
their own borders?
AMOS: First of all, I think it's important
to recognize that in all of the neighboring
countries -- in Jordan, in Lebanon, in Turkey
-- the majority of Syrians are not living
in camp situations. So, although there is
a kind of focus on camps -- I mean, particularly
in Jordan, and a focus on Zaatari Camp -- 75
to 80 percent of Syrian refugees in Jordan
are not in a camp situation. The numbers are
even higher in Lebanon. And again, the majority
of refugees even in Turkey, which has set
up a number of camps on the border, are not
in a camp situation.
So, the issue is not 'should camps be established'.
The issue is are -- is provision being made
to ensure that Syrians that are fleeing violence
in Syria are able to go to other countries
to be welcomed in those countries and to be
safe and secure in those countries.
And what my colleague Antonio Guterres from
the High Commission of Refugees is seeking
to do is to make sure that the huge burden
which is being place on particularly Jordan,
Lebanon and Turkey where the majority of the
over 3 million have gone -- in Lebanon, for
example, over 20 percent of the Lebanese population
is now made up of Syrian refugees. I always
use my own country, the United Kingdom, as
an example -- that would be the equivalent
of 12 million people turning up seeking entry
into the United Kingdom.
So, one, we have to recognize the support
that those neighboring countries require.
We also have to recognize that the majority
of refugees don't actually want to go too
far because they want to go home.
You know, they think -- you know, many -- many
people that I spoke to in the first few days
-- first few months of the conflict thought
it wouldn't last very long and they would
be back home by now. People are desperate
to go home to rebuild their lives. That does
not take away, I think, from the responsibility
of countries across the world to recognize
the major crisis that we are facing -- not
just in Syria.
For the first time ever, the total number
of displaced people and refugees across the
world has topped 50 million people -- for
the first time since about 1945; I shouldn't
say for the first time ever. These are huge
and significant numbers.
And I think in each and every country has
a responsibility, particularly given that
the burden's usually on the neighboring countries
and usually those neighboring countries are
themselves fragile. We all have a responsibility
to look to ourselves to give what support
we can.
RUPP: Well, please join me in thanking Valerie
Amos for her time.
(APPLAUSE)
AMOS: Thank you.
RUPP: Thank you all very much for coming.
END